[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 23
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast L I
am Francesc Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mike Mandel.
Hey Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy.
Very excited about the very
cool interview with Andy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, we've got a really
nice interview today
with a gentleman from
Humble Bundle, which
is a website that
I've been tracking
for a long time over the years.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I'm slightly ashamed.
I'm not really
ashamed, but whatever.
I actually did not
know who they were.
And I think I'm going to
start using them soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think it's just
to show that I play
more games than you do.
I think that's
probably what it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I play
Android games, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so that's
actually going to be
our main content of the week.
We're going to be talking
with Andy Oxfeld, which
is engineering manager
at Humble Bundle,
about how they use
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, it's going
to be really cool.
And then after that,
we have our question
of the week, where we're going
to be talking about Kubernetes
one more time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
People like it.
MARK MANDEL: They do.
They do really like it.
But before we do
that, I think you've
got a really interesting
cool thing of the week
that you managed to find.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So that's actually something
that I saw on Twitter
a couple days ago, and I thought
it was really interesting.
It's a ranking done by a
French organization that
is completely independent.
And I'm going to brag
about my accent now.
I'm going to say it's JDN,
which is [SPEAKING FRENCH].
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very French.
And they did a ranking
about the different features
of every single cloud
provider that we
have here in the United States.
And guess who came up first?
ANDY OXFELD: I don't know.
Maybe us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, and it is very cool.
So we'll have the link
in the show notes.
And I think it's like,
yeah, we are the first
on the general ranking.
We aren't the first on
every single ranking, which
is actually very
interesting for us,
too, because it kind of
shows what are the things we
need to improve on.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But also it shows
if you are trying to decide
which cloud you should go with,
there is going to be a
lot of different things
that you might be interested.
You're going to find them in
this report, so definitely
worth having a look.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so if you're
looking for certain trade-offs
from different providers,
obviously us included,
could be a really
interesting read.
Or if you're sort
of going, hey, I'd
really like to use
Google Cloud Platform,
but I need to have something
that sort of justifies
the usage or helps me sort
of make this argument,
this sounds like a document that
might be pretty handy for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And also the little
images that they
created with their
rankings, they're
super cute, so that's something
that it's always a bonus.
MARK MANDEL: That
definitely always helps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
very, very important.
Cool.
So I guess it's time
to go and talk to Andy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Let's talk about games.
We are joined today by Andy
Oxfeld from Humble Bundle.
Thank you so much for
joining us today, Andy.
ANDY OXFELD: Great to be here.
MARK MANDEL: So
let's have a chat.
First of all, let's
talk about you.
Who are you, what
do you do, what's
your background and stuff?
ANDY OXFELD: So I'm
an engineering manager
at Humble Bundle.
So I've been with the company
for almost four years,
and I've done a little
bit of everything.
I've worked on pretty much
every part of the code base
at some point, and I
originally have my background
in the gaming industry.
I worked at Electronic
Arts for a number of years
before coming to Humble Bundle.
So even though I'm not
working on games anymore,
I have a lot of
familiarity, and it
helps a lot, with our
mission as a company being
to support game developers.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So obviously we talked just a
little bit there about games.
Tell us what Humble Bundle
is, like it's history.
It's changed a bit over
the last few years,
but I was definitely around
when it first came out,
and I was really excited by it.
So tell us a little
bit about what it is.
ANDY OXFELD: So Humble
Bundle was actually
started by game developers.
So our two founders,
Jeff and John,
were originally working
at Wolfire games,
and they were creating
a ninja rabbit fighting
game called Overgrowth.
That company still exists,
and they're actually doing
really awesome things there.
But Humble Bundle came
out of a promotion
that Wolfire games was doing.
And they basically
wanted to create
kind of the most humble
promotion, hence the name.
And they decided,
what would be more
humble than being
cross-platform, completely
DRM free, and letting
the customer pay whatever
they want?
And so Humble Bundle
came up with a promotion
between-- included games
from Wolfire games as well as
a few other developers
and put them together
into the first Humble Bundle.
And it was so wildly successful
that our founders realized,
we should try this again.
And the second one was
also wildly successful.
And so they decided to split
it off into its own company.
And since then, really the
mission of Humble Bundle
has been to support
game developers
and create cool promotions
for the community.
MARK MANDEL: And not only did
it include pay what you want,
but also it included, you
could do donations to charity,
and also do that sort of stuff.
ANDY OXFELD: Absolutely.
So charity has always been an
important part of our mission,
and every project we've
created has some way
in which we support charity.
And today we've raised more
than $70 million for charity,
and that's something
we're really proud of
and something that we're going
to continue to do, and really
take to heart.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Excellent.
Now in the beginning, I
know it was very one-offish,
like you had these one
promotions and stuff like that,
though I know things are a
little bit different now.
Do you want to talk about how is
that different now versus then?
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah, so as
we grew and scaled up,
we started from a bundle would
come out every few months.
We'd have pretty long gaps
where there was almost nothing
on our website.
Existing customers
could come to it
to download the things
they had purchased,
but otherwise it's
nothing to do there.
And it was really a
big deal, I remember,
the first time that we
had back-to-back bundles,
where it was like, really, oh,
we've never tried this before.
This is crazy.
It was years ago, so now
it seems kind of the norm.
So now we're at the point we
have multiple bundles running
at the same time, and
we have other products
that we've created as well.
So now there's always tons of
things going on on our website.
But back where we were
kind of getting started,
things were definitely a lot
more sparse and a lot less
regular than they are now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
when you're saying
that you were very
successful at the beginning,
like every single bundle was a
wild success, how many people
accessing the
website, more or less?
What are we talking about?
ANDY OXFELD: In terms
of actual numbers,
I couldn't say numbers
actually accessing.
But I do know that we
were regularly seeing up
to a million purchasers
for our bundles,
and you'll continue to
see numbers like that.
Thinking about how I'm sure
many, many people always
visited and don't
purchase, so I think
we're almost definitely
looking at millions of visits,
but I couldn't give
you the exact number.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's
actually really cool
if you go on the website,
they do have the stats
at the bottom of the page.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What?
MARK MANDEL: That show
you total payments
split by operating system,
number of purchases.
I've been a longtime
Linux user, so I
used to go back on a
regular basis and be like,
hey, are Linux users paying more
than Windows users and stuff
like that, and actually
look at the numbers.
So a lot of that
stuff really exists,
and they highlight top
contributors and stuff
like that.
It's a pretty awesome
thing that you're doing.
ANDY OXFELD: Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: So you
said you were dealing
with millions and millions
of-- millions at the very least
of people buying products.
Let's talk a little bit
about the technology
that powers Humble Bundle
and what's going on there.
I believe you people
are using GCP.
ANDY OXFELD: Uh-huh,
that's correct.
We've been using App
Engine since day one,
and over time we've continued
to expand our usage of Google
Cloud Platform offerings.
And we're now using
Google Cloud Storage.
We're using BigQuery and
starting to use Google Compute
Engine as well.
And those have definitely
been critical to our success.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So could you tell us
a little bit more?
Why did you choose App
Engine at the beginning?
ANDY OXFELD: So we knew
that, as you mentioned,
our traffic was going
to be very spiky.
So the automatic
scaling of App Engine
was absolutely crucial
for our success,
and I don't think
the company really
could have worked without it.
So the fact that
there's basically--
without automatic
scaling, we could
have had-- if we had a
fixed number of servers,
there's two different
ways it could have gone.
So you could have either
had too few servers
and customers want to
come to our website,
things would have been slow
or wouldn't have worked,
and customers wouldn't have been
able to make all the purchases
they were able to make.
Or we would have had enough
servers to meet the demand,
but that would mean
that as soon as-- really
the first few hours of a bundle
have always been, by far,
when most of the
traffic comes in.
But the bundle runs for
two weeks, and by the end
it's more kind of a
trickle of purchases
compared to the beginning.
So we were paying
for all the service
that we needed to support
those initial few hours
at the end of the
bundle, our costs
would have been so
high that there's
no way the company could
have been profitable.
So the fact that App
Engine, without any thought
on our part, was able to
scale up and scale down
as we needed, we
didn't even have
to think about it, especially
when the company was really
small and we didn't have a big
team, it just allowed us to get
started and just focus on
selling games and doing
cool promotions and
not worrying about all
the little nitty-gritty
details of the tech.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So knowing that
Humble Bundle has
been out there for
quite a long time,
I don't think you're using Go.
So what language are you using?
ANDY OXFELD: So
we're using Python.
That was-- if I were
to do it all again,
I actually might
consider using Go.
I do like a lot of
things about Go.
But at this point,
I think we're pretty
much-- have so much
Python code written,
I think that's what
we're going to be.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what parts of App
Engine?
Like App Engine is
basically an ecosystem.
There's a bunch
of things inside.
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah.
So we definitely make extensive
use of the Cloud Datastore.
So the performance and
scalability of the data store
still amazes me to this day.
It's still almost
like magic to me
that this thing is able to work.
So I think we've over time
become-- I kind of describe us
as Datastore wizards, and
we know the ins and outs
of everything you can do
with it, and every trick
and how to-- both from how
to make things really fast
and how to keep costs
down and stuff like that.
So that's definitely a really
big part of our platform.
Task queues are also
really important to us,
so we use task queues.
The most crucial thing
that goes through
is our payment
processing is completely
based on task queues.
But we also use tasks
for different things,
like when we have something
that we want to schedule.
So for example, we often
will at like 10 AM every day
add new products onto
our store, and we want
to schedule it to be at 10 AM.
We used to have to have
someone that was there and had
to push a button.
But now, with task queues,
we can just schedule an event
and we just know
it's going to run.
And that's especially
important because since we
sell international
products, sometimes we
have so many time zones
such that people used
to have to be awake
at 1 AM in the morning
our time zone to launch
something in another time zone.
But now we just schedule it
and we know it's going to work,
and it just goes.
MARK MANDEL: So you're able to
leverage the ability of task
queues to retry if something
fails, and so you're like,
I know this is going
to work at some point.
This is going to be fine.
ANDY OXFELD: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
That's actually
very interesting,
the fact that you're using task
queues for the payment system.
Payments are a very
tricky thing to do.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about how you
manage that exactly?
And also, what are you using
for the payments themselves?
ANDY OXFELD: Yes.
So the real thing we use
it for is IPN handling.
So we don't actually do the
direct payment processing
ourselves.
We use PayPal.
We use Amazon, we use
Stripe, and we use
Coinbase and a couple others.
So early on, we found that
if we receive an IPN from one
of them-- so IPN stands for
instant payment notification,
and it's the main way in
which a company like PayPal
communicates.
It's almost like an API they
use to communicate with us.
And so sometimes, we
need the reliability
of knowing when an IPN
comes in that it's always
going to be processed.
So what we do now is when
an IPN-- when we essentially
receive a request from
PayPal saying, hey, here's
some data we need you
to process, what we do
is we immediately
write an entity
to the datastore containing
the contents of that IPN,
and then we schedule a
task to process that.
And so we know that no matter
what goes wrong, whether it's
sometimes an engineer on
our team makes a mistake
and there's a bug in
the code and it crashes,
we know that we're not
going to lose that data.
We can look at our
logs and figure out
exactly what went wrong and fix
the mistake and retry the task,
and ultimately we
can be confident
that it's going to be processed.
And that's really
important for us,
since we have really
complicated accounting,
since a big part of
what we actually do
is moving money to
different places.
So we need to make sure that
our developers, charities,
customers, can trust
us to make sure
that every penny
that we receive is
going to go to the right place.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that seems
really important, especially
with the pay what
you want model,
and the customers can choose
which companies get what,
and what charities get
what, and it's percentages.
So yeah, it's not as simple as
that thing's $10 and thing's 5,
and we're going to
receive everything.
ANDY OXFELD: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So you mentioned that
you're using App Engine.
You're using Datastore.
You're using task queues.
What else are you
using from App Engine?
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah, let's see--
MARK MANDEL: I think you said--
ANDY OXFELD: We use Memcache.
So Memcache is incredibly
important for performance
for us, since we want
our site to load quickly.
And Memcache also helps
us cut down on our costs,
since accessing the
datastore directly costs
more money than using Memcache.
We actually recently switched
to dedicated Memcache,
which we found actually, despite
the fact that it costs money,
in the end it actually
brought down our costs because
of the fact that I think
it actually decreased
other usages, front-end instance
hours and things like that,
to the point where it almost
certainly saves us more money
than we actually spent on it.
So that was
definitely a big win.
And not only that,
but that of course
makes our site even
faster, since we're
able to store more
data in the cache.
MARK MANDEL: So
you were actually
using the shared Memcache
instance for a long time.
ANDY OXFELD: We were using
that for quite a long time.
MARK MANDEL: And so you'd get
kicked out every so often.
You'd get your data kicked out.
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah.
And the other thing
about the shared
is that over time, it kind
of varies how much you have.
So there's times when
your performance is better
and times when it's worse.
But with dedicated Memcache,
it's very predictable.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
Now, I think you also said you
started using BigQuery a bit
as well.
Talk us a little
bit through what
made you make that decision
and what you're doing with it.
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah,
so we originally
started using BigQuery
for our accounting system.
So we used to, every month-- so
we pay developers and charities
that sell through us.
We cut them a check
every month for however
much that we owe them.
And then we used to have
this complicated map job,
essentially, where
we would go over
every order in the datastore.
And then we realized over
time that that was not
scaling to our needs.
And so what we now
do is we leverage
the automated backup technology
that App Engine provides
to back up from-- I think
it uses Google Cloud
Storage as an intermediary,
but in the end
it ends up in BigQuery.
And so once we have all
our order data in BigQuery,
we're able to do really powerful
analysis on our order data
in seconds.
And so we have kind of a
complicated set of BigQuery
queries that we've essentially
built over time that we
kind of run and put together.
And basically now it's a
fairly automated process
by which it now actually
every day kind of spits out,
OK, well, here's how
much money everyone that
sells through here is owed.
We don't really have
to worry about-- it
used to take hours and hours.
Now it's seconds.
So that's been a really,
really great boon for us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So then, what you said
is that you're actually
dumping the whole
datastore to Cloud Storage,
and then uploading
it back to BigQuery
so you can do all your queries.
Nice.
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah.
And so we also-- in
addition to that,
we also have been
taking advantage
of streaming in BigQuery.
So we also stream
our data as well.
And we like to use both,
because we can kind of
check for discrepancies
and just be
100% confident that every order
is represented in BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
So basically you're
taking advantage of two
of our big managed services.
So I'm guessing you still
don't have much of an ops team
at the company.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDY OXFELD: So we have
no ops team at all.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
ANDY OXFELD: We completely
are able to rely on the Cloud
Platform.
And again, that's wonderful,
because just to be honest,
none of us wanted to do ops.
[LAUGHTER]
Not what our background's in.
And so it lets us
focus on writing code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is a very good point.
So what else do you use for--
so you mentioned Cloud Storage.
You use it for temporary
backup for datastore.
Do you use it something
else, like your images
or some binaries or whatever?
ANDY OXFELD: Yep.
Our other big thing is serving
images, as you mentioned.
So we've actually
started building
a suite of internal
tools around it
that allows-- so we
have a team internally
that makes sure all
the image assets
for the various
promotions we put together
are in the right place.
So they'll offload all the
assets into Google Cloud
Storage, and so essentially what
our engineering team has built
is essentially
kind of like a CMS,
like a content management system
for putting bundles together,
that another team in our
company uses to actually put
the bundles together.
And so Google Cloud
Storage allows
us to do this,
because originally,
when we were kind of tiny
and when our engineers used
to build every bundle by
hand, and then every time we
wanted to change what
bundle was active,
we had to deploy the site.
But now that we're able to use
Google Cloud Storage to host
the images, we can just upload
the images to Google Cloud
Storage, reference the
images from the live site
and not have to deploy.
So that's been a really
big win for us as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So since you
mentioned deploying,
how often do you deploy?
ANDY OXFELD: Probably
like 10 times a day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice
ANDY OXFELD: Sometimes more.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
Is that actually
code deployments,
or just changes to
the database, or both?
ANDY OXFELD: Code deployments.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How many modules do
you have, or it's
just one big module?
ANDY OXFELD: So we have almost--
probably 95% of our code base
is in one module.
Then we have a few
other tinier modules.
The most notable one is we've
built a uploader, which uses--
or CDN, which is-- a
separate company does that.
So we've built an uploader
that the uploader does
run in App Engine, and so
that is a separate module that
is kind of a very isolated
problem we wanted to solve.
And so that's able to
live separately and use
different technologies,
which is nice.
MARK MANDEL: Do you store
the binaries for the games,
or is that done
by a third party?
What's the [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDY OXFELD: We do
store the binaries,
and that's what the CDN does.
And that's what this uploader
module does is uploads
the binaries to our CDN.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
curious, what would you
consider probably the biggest
challenge you've encountered
when building Humble Bundle
working with Google Cloud
Platform?
What's been sort of
the trickiest problem
that you've come across?
ANDY OXFELD:
Definitely scalability,
although App Engine's
tools definitely
provide solutions to that.
It comes down to
often we'll write
our code-- problem one is always
just get the code working.
And so for example, when we
built the Humble store, which
is a bit of a more
traditional storefront
that, unlike our bundles,
which are pay what you want,
the Humble store is
fixed-price sales.
When we first built
that, we put together
in just a couple weeks.
Then at the time, we
only had 10 games on it.
So the original
solution we built
for it was not scalable at all.
We were actually dumping the
entire inventory directly
to the browser.
So at first, it
loaded pretty fast.
When we hit 50 games, it
started to be a little slower.
Once we had 100
games on the store,
the store was taking
about 10 seconds to load,
and we realized we were going to
have to use a better approach.
And so we looked
at the technologies
App Engine provided, and we were
able to leverage task queues
and Memcache and build a
more sophisticated system
that now we do a much smarter
approach, where we only
send the games that the
browser needs to know about.
And so now we have
thousands and thousands
of games on our store, and
the store loads very fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And something that our
customers very often wonder
is, how do you monitor
all these systems?
ANDY OXFELD: So we have a
number of ways we do that.
So we have a bunch of things
we've kind of built internally
on top of the log
system in App Engine.
So we have Cron jobs that
run every few minutes that
check the logs, look for
exceptions and stuff like that.
If they're above a
certain threshold,
they'll actually ping
our phones, occasionally
in the middle the night.
But it lets us know
when things go wrong.
And we also have dashboards
that we look at, some of which
we built by hand.
I actually check our App
Engine usage every day
just to make sure if our
numbers are going too high,
in case an engineer
actually deployed
some code that's doing
tons and tons of datastore
reads that we don't want.
That way we catch it before our
bill ends up going too high.
More recently,
we've been starting
to look into some of the
new Stackdriver things.
So we're just kind of starting
to wrap our heads around that
and see how we can
take advantage of that.
But we've already set
up a few custom metrics,
and we're looking
at the dashboards
there and starting to
see-- it's definitely
really exciting
technology, and we're just
starting to figure
out how we can use it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, I was totally
thinking about Stackdriver,
when you said it's
like, yeah, it pings me
in the middle of the night.
We can do that as a service.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Midnight
wake-up call as a service.
I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So could you
mention-- you already
talked about what were
the hardest things.
What about the best thing?
What is the moment
where you said, wow,
it's cool to be
running on the cloud?
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah, so there's
definitely a number of those.
I mean, it's really cool when
we launch a bundle and you just,
as you mentioned, there's a live
calendar of how many people are
purchasing at the
bottom, and just
seeing all these
people coming in
and thinking about just how
many requests are being handled.
And the fact that we didn't
have to worry about that
is just an amazing thing.
It's also really
satisfying when we've
done some cool
optimization tasks
we've done that have found
ways of making our site faster.
It's really cool
when sometimes we've
have pages that are taking
a little longer to load,
and we've realized,
oh, hey, if we
use the datastore in
this different way,
or if we add some
Memcache on top of this,
and we get down to
100 milliseconds.
So those have been cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
I have a question that
is super technical,
but I'm very curious about
how you're doing this.
So I'm looking at the Humble
Bundle webpage right now,
and I can see the bundles sold.
And it's noticed
that it changes.
So are you using web circuits,
web circuits with App Engine?
How does that work?
ANDY OXFELD: So we're actually
using PubNub for that.
So there's a startup called
PubNub that essentially
provides a kind of
pub sub style thing
where you can basically push
notifications from the server
side to the browser.
And their technology makes
that really easy to do.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
very interesting,
because I know that we have
some-- there's the web--
I think App Engine socket APS--
MARK MANDEL: Channels API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That I
have not used that much,
but I was very curious about it.
ANDY OXFELD: Yeah,
we haven't actually
looked too much
into that either,
but I do think it is probably
pretty similar to the service
PubNub provides.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was in
between that or Firebase, so
yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
Excellent.
Cool.
Is there anything we haven't
talked about but you'd
like to highlight, or
you think is particularly
interesting about what's
going on behind the scenes
at Humble Bundle?
ANDY OXFELD: Well, one
thing I do want to highlight
is that we are hiring
software engineers.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
ANDY OXFELD: So our website
is jobs.HumbleBundle.com.
And we definitely
encourage anyone
interested to check it out.
Having experience in
Google Cloud Platform
is definitely a big
plus for us, so yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
if anyone ends up
applying to Humble Bundle
because of this podcast,
I'd love to know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because I think
that maybe they have a referral
bonus or something.
ANDY OXFELD: Maybe.
MARK MANDEL: I think the
other big question is, are you
a PC or a console gamer?
ANDY OXFELD: I'm a PC gamer.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
ANDY OXFELD: So StarCraft
2 has for many years
been my weapon of choice,
and masters league.
So we definitely at
Humble Bundle have a mix.
We have some hard-core
PC gamers and we have
some hard-core console gamers.
But I'm definitely a PC gamer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I think we should go visit
them at their office one day.
ANDY OXFELD: You guys
are welcome, absolutely.
Any day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to come by the office
and talk to us today.
ANDY OXFELD: Absolutely.
Great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So thanks again to Andy for such
an interesting conversation.
I really learned a lot about
how they use the Google Cloud
Platform, but also I learned
a lot about cool things
like they actually are
very active on charity.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, Humble Bundle is a really
interesting project, just
from a business perspective
if nothing else,
as well as the
stuff they've been
doing for selling
games, and indie games
and all sorts of good stuff.
It's a project I've tracked
for a really long time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm not sure buying more games
is a very good idea for me
right now, because--
MARK MANDEL: You can never
have enough games, ever.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
don't have enough time either.
So I don't know.
There's a trade-off
to be done in there.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's go with the question
of the week, which is, as we
said before, about Kubernetes.
And it came through Google+
from one of our previous
interviewees.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, and
very active commenter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very active.
Hi Heron.
We know you're hearing.
You're listening to us.
MARK MANDEL: So Heron said us
a really cool question, one
that I've definitely
heard before,
a discussion around the fact
that Kubernetes 1.2 doesn't
have any idea of Cron.
So if you want to, say, set
up a scheduled task that
does something on a regular
basis, say once a day
or once an hour,
something like that,
Kubernetes doesn't
have anything built in.
So how do you end up doing that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I guess that it
is important to
mention that it's not
part of Kubernetes as
1.2, but it's planned
to be released with 1.3.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
what do you do then?
MARK MANDEL: So I think you
have a couple of options there.
One of maybe-- maybe the
most basic one is you
can set up a Cron just on a
GCE instance, one of the nodes
on Kubernetes just using
standard Linux Cron,
running the commands
and doing that stuff,
and to set up a job.
Now, actually I'll backtrack
for a minute and say,
Kubernetes does have
a concept of jobs.
So if you have a
one-off task or one-off
process you want to run, have
it be managed by Kubernetes,
make sure it gets finished,
that sort of stuff,
jobs are definitely a
thing you need to look at.
But what you'd
want to do is you'd
want to fire off that
job on a regular basis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so jobs, I'd say,
jobs is more like
things like map
reduce and stuff like
that, where you have,
these need to be
processed at some point.
Just do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, but so you're
saying that basically you
could start one of those jobs
through a call down
from an instance,
a GCE instance running Cron.
MARK MANDEL: Running
Cron, that would work.
That would be OK.
But there's actually
nothing stopping you
from using the Cron
ability within App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I actually
like that much better.
MARK MANDEL: I like
this much better, too.
Obviously then it's
a managed service.
You absolutely know it's
never going to go down.
Like if that GCE
instance died in a ball
of fire, that would be bad.
And you may not know, or
you'd need monitoring.
But
Kubernetes has an
API, so you can set it
up so that you can fire off a
job using the API from at App
Engine, and then
you can probably
feel a whole lot happier
about it that it's happening
and it's always going to
happen at the time it's
meant to happen.
I think that's my favorite.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Also, the thing that I like
about this solution is that
it's-- so Cron on App Engine
is based on task queues,
which means that
if, for any reason,
the request that you're sending
fails, it will retry it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's also a bonus.
You're basically
just winning there.
I think it even comes with
exponential backoff and all
of those really fancy
things if you need to.
So it's very easy to set up.
And it's very reliable.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
So I think that's
definitely the way I'd go,
especially obviously running
on Google Cloud Platform.
I think that's an easy solution.
And with the scale to zero
of the extended App Engine,
you're not paying for
very much, either.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
Well, before we finish
with this amazing episode,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about what
you're going to be doing soon?
MARK MANDEL: So we discussed
in the last episode as well,
but I will be in Kentucky
as of end of next week.
I'll be seeing
Vector Conf talking
about games in the cloud,
doing a little roundtable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I think
that when you say next week,
it's this week, because--
MARK MANDEL: It is this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is this week.
MARK MANDEL: It is this week.
You're right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're recording.
For once, we're actually are
recording with days in advance.
MARK MANDEL: Days
in advance, yeah.
So this week I will
be in Kentucky.
So I'll be at
Vector Conf talking
about games in the cloud.
And then after that,
I'll be at the Louisville
GDG talking about Kubernetes.
I know you're going on
a little travel as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm going
to be in Budapest, Hungary.
It's going to be pretty awesome.
It's going to be for
CraftConf, and I'm
going to be running a Go
workshop at CraftConf.
There's going to be many
other people, very cool people
like Kelsey Hightower.
He's going to be doing
a Kubernetes workshop.
I know that
[? Afir ?], he's going
to be there talking about
these [INAUDIBLE] systems.
Jessie Frazelle is going to
be there, talking about--
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds like
a lot of really fun people
that I want to hang out
with and learn from.
So that's going to be very fun.
MARK MANDEL: And I believe
it also went live recently,
you're going to be
speaking at Google I/O.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
be speaking at Google I/O. Yeah,
pretty excited about that.
More work.
So yeah, Google I/O, it's
going to be in Mountain View
this year.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's going
to be from May 18 to May 20.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And yeah, I'm going
to be talking about Cloud Spin.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I'll be there as well.
I'll be talking about
multiplayer games
using Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and we'll actually
be somewhere hanging
out around there.
So we'll give you more
details on exactly how it
is going to work.
But if you're planning
on attending Google I/O,
let us know and say hi.
MARK MANDEL: We'd
love to say hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you again, Mark,
for joining me this week.
And thank you, all the
listeners, for joining us.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Great to have everyone.
And don't forget,
you want to send us
questions of the week or things
that are cool, please do so.
We'd love to hear from you all.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]